yeah welcome welcome to this video let's
see me shook dl down last video the
video before that or wrong the game
before that but i did not upload the
video of it because it was a again it
kind of gets worse on cheating cheating
person i'm thinking about if i should
make a video about it trying to explain
my rationale why I think he was cheating
but I don't know it's kind of damn it's
just it's investing time on stuff that
is really so unpleasant why do why do
people do it I don't get it I don't
really get it well let's see the guys
some report it and would see what
happens ok I'm playing against me shook
dl high rated i am it's a bit strange is
his way of handling the hoopla here is
not really great to be perfectly honest
I'm this is even giving away in exchange
yeah it was a good position anyhow but
this is of course quite nice that I even
got an extra exchange now ok let's put
the night only for that's a good good
spot for this piece and go from there
yeah it was a nice position as mentioned
anyhow but an exchange oh it's nice to
have not not always but most of the time
yeah 11 idea here is to open up with a
six and b5 and i think it's a it's a
good idea of course them this helps them
to get rid of his double porn but the
remaining the remaining structure is so
good for me so no worries yeah should I
just take the to know it's probably the
easiest way to play just take that if I
take on c4 now he will get a counter
play on these six so it's probably not
not the best way before keeps things
closed yeah it's not not bad before but
I still wonder if I still should just
take but it's a bit unpleasant or wait i
have rookie one sorry it's not
unpleasant i have rupee one i totally
forgot about that one rookie one year's
king of two so I am crime oh c'mon king
of two I have no dissonance than yummy i
was a bit stupid would be one king of
two not really have no no good reply
then yeah I didn't really want to get to
this this kind of passive cover of the
six but what can you do
I take here he takes d6 might come we
might activate mallets let's just keep
things under control take here ninety
six outs I have possibly look be too
it's probably would be too hard a seat
cover cover anything here then rookie
two should be should be enough right
yeah so I was thinking hook be too right
he's got Queen f3 and then he
counter-attacks him now that's true it's
really true hmm okay if I go look d8 can
go back to see form and that somehow
continues one night if form yeah let it
daddy play that really badly you
shouldn't have gotten any kind of
counter play really okay it's got this
one check let's get rid of the rope here
check
check I cannot take on d5 unfortunately
due to due to this Knight f6 check
business always the the fork
check time morning to a queen f's if
Queen if we take for Queen f6 right hmm
okay don't want to they allow that just
cover f6 and the long diagonal
yeah the night and I have the C porn so
that really should be okay 40 seconds
are somewhat worrisome check it's a
check check white resign yeah I almost
bungled it up yeah by some by some to
Ryan Oh superficial moves yeah this is
the one of the main lines of the office
of this opening the hoopin a variation
of the NIMS oh and what was strange is
the move f form this is just a mistake
and it's surprising then what Wright
needs to do he has to play Quincy to
cover f5 so that I cannot after possible
later on f4 takes takes I cannot play
Bishop f5 so what I'm trying to say is
let's say I play any move might not be
six or so and then his idea is to play
that one and prevent my Bishop f5 I want
to trade those bishops this Bishop is
always putting pressure on the Kings
side and this would be nice to trade and
also to block on their five square so
that his c1 bishop is not getting active
what he did is he played FY immediately
and this allows the trade IAM right now
okay he can theoretically speaking go to
e2 but this is not helping he had he BP
goes to this trade and now he just
blundered 93 kind of weird but neither
f3 it would be normal and here i have a
position that is very nice i have those
two excellent nights i have 90 form
coming rookie a droopy for i mean all
kinds of ideas on those efore and III
square one why it is basically nothing
you can try to push my my nights but I
always have h5 to block and the black
super idea is simply due to the fact
that we have a have one night a very
strong one against this very bad bishop
on see one that always all just look at
this or alternatively at this the bishop
can never be activated and in the long
run there's also the simple problem that
this Bishop does not ever cover see form
so end games with minor pieces two
nights against nida Bishop I very often
just very good for black because the the
big points here this whole formation
will would be would be a deciding yeah
in the game he blundered the exchange
and I certainly could have could have
played this a bit better yeah maybe the
idea would be five wasn't the best it
wasn't bad but it it is some yeah it is
also not very necessary yeah okay be
take so strong I am should have sent a
thought a moment about that yeah I
actually I saw that but will this is
this is really easy okay but objectively
speaking I think it was winning all of
the time it was just very it was just a
bit a bit shaky yeah because um it was
much much better at one atom at an
earlier stage Oh looky droop t8 is
actually a big mistake I have to play
look II five here you can take on f7
interesting it's kind of surprising that
this is working but it does okay so
takes check and then all sundays got a
ton of checks es got a pepsi show here
cannot cannot go out funny but even went
back then here I'm probably winning
again check check
yeah yeah yeah I'm winning again but
that was shaky i should have played it
much more yeah more precise way so that
he doesn't get the the counterclaim say
the name in the Dimitri misheck okay
that's actually his real name okay well
thanks for watching